I want to talk next about one of the the
real implications of this bogus Arizona
audit that's taking place of absentee
ballots looking for bamboo fibers and
all sorts of other stuff uh the the
impact of the Arizona audit is not going
to be
Joe Biden retroactively loses Arizona
the impact of the Arizona audit is not
going to be Joe Biden is removed from
the White House and Trump is reinstated
to use the word that they've been
throwing around for the last week or so
but there is going to be an impact from
this audit and there's a really good
article in NPR about this by Miles Parks
called experts call it a clown show but
Arizona audit is a disinformation
blueprint
um explaining it's not an audit it's an
audit in name only according to Matt
Masterson a former Department of
Homeland Security official who helped
lead the election security prep for the
last election he says it's a threat to
the overall confidence of democracy all
in pursuit of continuing a narrative
that we know to be a lie this is a
really important thing to understand
maybe there are people who think the
Arizona audit and the search for bamboo
fibers and all of this stuff could lead
to a change in the Arizona results or a
change in the 2020 results overall it's
not going to but even without achieving
that it still is achieving something
that should be very scary to all of us
which is it continues to put in people's
minds the idea that our elections are
just a free-for-all they don't work when
a candidate wins by millions and
millions of votes maybe they actually
lost by millions and millions of votes
and it just further reinforces the idea
that hey the election results are sort
of like opinion much the same way where
you might like one flavor bubble tea and
I like a different flavor or I might
think that one type of cherry ice cream
is good and you might say no Cherry
Garcia is the best one right
it equates on a position on abortion
like what's my opinion about whether
abortion shouldn't be legal to who won
is just an opinion and we can challenge
it and we can use any mechanism that we
can think of to try to challenge that
that's the crisis that Matt Masterson is
pointing out here
Masterson says the strategy chosen by
the Arizona Republican state senate
leaders is working as intended to
undermine confidence in the outcome of
last year's vote and this is the point
even if it doesn't overturn it it
undermines confidence in elections in
general the process is a simple exercise
in how disinformation spreads and takes
hold in 2021 and experts fear it
presents a blueprint for other states
and lawmakers to follow one that's
already showing signs of being emulated
across the country and this is the key
line right here Masterson says now we
have a playbook out there where if you
don't like the results by the way in an
election that wasn't particularly close
you claim you didn't lose and in fact
the process itself was rigged against
you and the steps are first create a
false reality
that's the first step
the second step is hit the airwaves
which they did very early and continue
to do
the third step is use doubt to sow more
doubt and then you go into next election
with people already primed to doubt
whatever it is uh that they hear from
you that is the three-step process and
unfortunately
I don't know if these people are Evil
Geniuses who are thinking hey you know
what
this Arizona thing's not going to
accomplish anything in terms of Arizona
2020. but this is going to see doubt and
it'll create a pretext for people to
claim any election we lose was
fraudulent I don't know that they're
really Evil Geniuses and they're
thinking in those terms but it doesn't
matter because that's the effect that it
has and so much like I said in the last
segment when we start seeing these new
Trump rallies supposedly later this
month maybe not until July when we start
seeing them
what is going to be the mood of the
people in the crowd about the legitimacy
the legitimacy of any election because I
believe that what we're going to see
here very clearly is you know Trump's
going to pick his favorites for 2022 and
maybe a whole bunch of them are going to
lose maybe some will win we don't yet
know but if they lose yes it hurts
Trump's shot at 2024 if he can't
successfully be the king maker in 2022
but does anybody have any doubt that
they're going to say guys listen
Democrats control the house now
Democrats control the Senate Joe Biden
controls the White House of course they
rigged it of course they rigged it so it
seems to me a foregone conclusion if
they don't get what they want in 2022
they're going to say it was all
fraudulent and the stuff they're doing
now including in Arizona is going to be
used as a pretext to Gin up the idea
that if you don't like the results it's
totally legit now in American politics
to say the results were rigged very
scary stuff let me know what you think
you can find me on Twitter at dpacman
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the David packman
show is supporting some of our awesome
sponsors today one of those awesome
sponsors is sheath underwear a lot of us
know all too well about the sticking and
the rubbing and the chafing with
traditional underwear especially this
time of year as the weather is getting
warm sheath underwear have created
unique boxer briefs with multiple
ergonomic compartments in the front
preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays separate comfortable
dry and cool no more sweatiness no more
chafing no more readjusting it's a
lifesaver sheath underwear is giving the
David Pacman show audience 20 off when
you go to sheathunderwear.com Pacman and
use the promo code Pac-Man give sheath
underwear a shot I've had a great
experience I believe you will too you
can find the link underneath this video
and don't forget to use promo code
Pacman for 20 off